[Musik]
das hier ist übrigens unsere Karre für
die nächsten sieben Tage ich finde es
wirklich sehr sehr geräumig und auch von
der Ausstattung her haben wir wirklich
nur das Beste gewählt
[Musik]
gerade im Hotel angekommen und ich habe
den nicht gesagt dass ich irgendwas mit
Social Media Mut habe aber plötzlich
kommen wir hier rein und hier liegen
überall einfach so ausgedruckte
Instagram Fotos von mir äh
[Musik]
ein neuer Tag im Paradies
sind gerade wach geworden wollten
duschen gehen und sehen plötzlich hier
einfach überall tausende Ameisen die an
der Seite an der Dusche hochkrabbeln
hier unten über den Boden krabbeln und
komplett einfach unser Hotelzimmer
zusammengefasst haben wir bisher nur
Regen
und ein riesiges ameisenproblem
was macht man bei Regen auf Ibiza
wandern
wenn ich jetzt wann dann
und das ist echt eine richtig schöne
Ecke laufen hier diesen berggrad hoch
auf der Insel Pirat Tempo wie
Taschentücher
der war gar nicht geplant
dass diese Insel wunderschön ist
kommunizieren
hier sieht so brutal aus einfach wie
wir sind jetzt gerade in Ibiza Stadt
gelandet und sind in dem Laden Paradise
Lost alex hat in unserem Fohlen er ist
doch geil hier Leute
schaut euch mal an wie schön ist sie auf
Ibiza Stadt ist willst du Lichterketten
und halt so schönes habe ich mir extra
meine Sonnenbrille aufgesetzt weil ich
Laser heute unterwegs alles klar
[Musik]
es ist 15 Uhr meine Damen und Herren wir
waren gestern tatsächlich im DC ten
einem der besten House Clubs der Welt
unterwegs und dreimal durch die raten
wer von Firat und mir getrunken hat und
wenn nüchtern geblieben ist
ich zeige euch mal
guten Morgen ja schon wieder morgen wir
befinden uns jetzt hier in San josef in
Ibiza
also ich habe das ja wirklich noch nie
eine Restaurant eine Karte gesehen die
so korrupt auseinanderfällt ich bin so
ein verfressenes Stück Scheiße ich kenne
übrigens keine Klingel die so nervig ist
wie die von unserem Hotelzimmer
[Musik]
gekommen
weil er jetzt hier schläft dadurch das
Vierrad die ganze Nacht immer schnarcht
und ich die ganze Nacht immer furze ist
es jetzt einfach nur
ist gut
[Musik]
GTR morgens oder abendscheißen
schreibt es in die Kommentare
[Musik]
ich gehe irgendwie nur morgens weil wenn
ich abends gehen im ersten Tag schönes
Wetter hier
ne auch hier
mit uns geil
am ersten Tag sein Frühstück
herausfindet beim Befehl und das dann
jeden Tag einfach wieder ist
[Musik]
hast du gefragt ne oder
5:40 Uhr
gemacht
[Musik]
Freitag also unser dritt letzter Tag
der nee
wann fliegen wie ich im Wasser Handstand
mache
[Musik]
Urlaubs wir sind gerade am Pool
angekommen
wir haben gerade so schön geschlafen und
auf einmal honiger Musik auf 1000
Dezibel an
[Musik]
da vorne findet einfach eine Hochzeit
statt und ich bin so Single dass ich
einfach mit dem Typen immer die ganze
Zeit nur am schlafen ist also das hier
ist das hässlichste Auto was ich hier
gesehen habe
ich weiß nicht mehr was das für eine
Marke ist
es ist
man nervt mich nervt mich
Abreisetag 7 wir gehen noch mal an Pool
filmen
Schaft
[Musik]
ich habe übrigens viele Fragen auf
Instagram bekommen warum wir nicht über
Airbnb oder so ein Haus gemietet haben
sondern in einem Hotel waren dass sie
tatsächlich ganz einfach daran weil
Hotel ohne el einfach ich bin
das passt
einfach verboten dass man Bäume in
seinem Handgepäck mit einem
mache ich sonst immer
marcelona
action
ja
wir wollten Joggen gekauft habe und der
steht goldener Witz
von Ibiza zurück hatten die ganze Zeit
nur da irgendwie Partys und waren da mit
irgendwelche DJ unterwegs
unfassbar aber ja sorry Leute die Jokes
waren wirklich nur
für die Tonne
euer Lieblingsblogger Sandra moin moin
meine aktiven Leute ich brauche echt
davon 15
auf jeden Fall bin ich direkt vom
Flughafen hier rüber gefahren ins
Podcast Studio wir nehmen Sandra das hat
niemand gefragt ja
ich wollte auf jeden Fall Podcast
Studium gerade schon direkt eine neue
Folge von euch aufgenommen wird Mittwoch
um 20 Uhr bei RTL online an der Stelle
will ich aber tatsächlich auf den Block
beenden sondern mach mal
en tschüss